how do you stay focused and grounded
when all you want to think about is
surviving and and keeping your family
alive well I think that's the grounding
thing for Madison is the ultimate
priority for protecting your family yeah
that's basically it now there's a huge
moment in this season a spoiler alert if
you haven't seen it but a Jeremiah gone
just know what was shot how would I
react I found out coming up here I
didn't have any idea and then Dave Toni
CJ I said I'm what yeah but that was a
drinking point I did I did
whoa whoa wait yeah that's what they
told me you heard it yeah I'm dead all
right Jay actions oh so strongly to that
have you you have any response for them
like their feelings about it I feel for
you I do I feel for you people I wish I
wasn't dead but he killed me that man
right there
killed hi well what he brought yeah - go
ahead on I pushed them into it yes yeah
it was a marquee with Murder on the
Orient Express is there any it took more
than one to kill they've reached up yeah
they planned it didn't kill him with a
meat cleaver like Arabic is there any
appealing to this man here when you when
you think that you might be on the
chopping block and you go it what you do
is you do not pick up your phone if he
calls you you screen your calls and you
you know it like he probably called me
like a year ago and I'm still on it I
just ignored it